on ouvre maintenant notre second débat
avec ce thème l'avenir de la planète et
donc de notre économie passe-t-il par la
décroissance ce modèle économique est
basé depuis des décennies sur ce
triptyque produire consommer et jeter
faut-il inventer un nouveau modèle
certains vont jusqu'à la décroissance
regardez ce reportage c'est une mère de
famille en seine-saint-denis portrait de
cendras et requiert
ça va quand sa deuxième fille aînée il y
a huit ans chez n'da a commencé à passer
au crible ses besoins pour moins
consommer donc on n'est pas obligé
d'acheter neuf et on peut acheter sap
est la seconde main voilà donc et tout
ça ça fait qu'à un moment on va produire
un peu moins de
aussi
plus aucun vêtement neuf
cette mère de famille économistes ou
fabriquent cosmétiques et produits
ménagers arrêter de manger de la viande
il ya un an devenu ce qu'on appelle une
décroissance pour lutter contre le
dérèglement climatique
décroissance il ya ça sonne un peu de
façon brutale et moi c'est plus du bon
sens quelque chose de très naturel à la
fin c'est vrai que quand on le regarde
de l'extérieur ça peut sembler un peu
drastiques mais dans notre mode de vie
ça s'est vraiment mis en place
progressivement naturellement maintenant
c'est pas forcément facile à assumer
dans d'autres cercles professionnels ou
ou bas dès lors que le renard avec son
vélo et qu'on dit qu'on mange pas de
viande on est tout de suite vu comme une
espèce de quelqu'un qui est en rupture
ou qui se veut militant alors que moi
j'ai pas du tout le sentiment d'être
militantes seins fini les supermarchés
chenda fait ses courses dans une
coopérative près de chez elle pour
favoriser les circuits courts elle
essaye d'aller chaque fois plus loin
dans sa démarche
mais ce sont limitées
pour les décroissants qui vont vraiment
au bout de la logique effectivement un
moment on en marge de la société et on
est dans quelque chose qui finalement
peut pas faire plus difficilement
engendrer des mouvements de masse les
membres de la coopérative discute
souvent de ce changement de modèle trop
marginal encore selon le cas beaucoup
plus de gens en fait si on leur explique
s il ordonnait les possibilités de
comprendre la démarche s'ils avaient de
la publicité autour de sa autour de ce
mode de vie là je pense que les gens ils
penseraient pas que ce soit si compliqué
que ce soit réservé à une une sorte
d'élite sentait assez simple dans le
principe mais qu' il n'y a pas les
moyens de le faire persuadé que cette
insuffisance de moyens est dû à un
manque de volonté politique
il regrette que le terme de décroissance
soit encore trop stigmatiser
la décroissance est-ce une solution
d'avenir voilà comment on a titré ce
débat débat des cas les débats plus
prospectif dans ce sens public
j'accueille denis olivennes
bonsoir bienvenue patrons de presse vous
diriger libération vous êtes essayiste
également aux publié un étrange
renoncement c'est chez albin michel
dominique méda bonsoir ça bienvenue
directrice du laboratoire de sciences
sociales de l'université paris-dauphine
vous êtes président de l'institut veblen
c'est un think tank et vous avez publié
de nombreux livres sur la poste
croissance ox et le terme qui préférait
employer notamment la mystique de la
croissance commence en libérer c'est
chez flammarion thomas parouty bonsoir
bonsoir en date heure de lagence mieux
vous êtes conseil en communication
auprès des entreprises qui sont engagés
dans la transition environnementale et
sociétale et vous participez c'est
intéressant parce qu'on en a pas de
temps que parler que ça dans l'actualité
à la convention des entreprises pour le
climat 150 entreprises de toutes tailles
qui est en train de se réunir pour
essayer d'inventer des solutions avec
nous en visioconférence or laluque et
députée européenne
économiste bonsoir bienvenue merci
d'être avec nous publiez vous avez
publié reconquête au nom de l'intérêt
général aux éditions les petits matins
bienvenue à vous aussi laetitia cru pas
éditorialistes qui est toujours à mes
côtés peut-être pour commencer denis
olivennes va partir du on aime bien se
faire ça nous les journalistes d'un d'un
portrait pour pour élargir un petit peu
le débat le portrait de cette mère de
famille voilà qui qui quotidiennement
fait en sorte de moins consommer vous en
pensez quoi mais que du bien moi je n'ai
aucun problème avec les gens qui font le
choix délibéré d'un mode de consommation
alternatif différent circulaire j'ai
moi-même été les 20 pays pis donc je
n'ai aucun problème avec ça c'est mon
sujet le sujet pour moi n'est pas les
comportements individuels et le degré de
responsabilité de chacun d'entre nous
estiment nécessaire moi même j'ai c'est
d'être responsable dans ma consommation
le sujet qui nous occupe est me
semble-t-il n'est pas tellement celui là
le sujet c'est globalement
collectivement est-ce que nous pouvons
vivre dans un monde sans croissance ce
qui est d'ailleurs quasiment notre cas
et quels sont les effets de cette non
croissance demain peut-être de cette
décroissance essayez vous mentent
duplique ou s'inspirent de voilà deux
des choix que faisait cette dame on peut
on pourrait considérer qu'on rentre dans
une décroissance oui mais d'abord
j'ai chaud je reprends le sujet d'un peu
plus loin si vous le permettez donc moi
je me suis intéressé à la question de
savoir pourquoi en effet nous avions
progressivement sinon rompu avec la
croissance du moins que nous étions
rentrés dans un cycle d'affaiblissement
de la croissance ya en 40 ans nous
étions le cinquième pays du monde par sa
richesse par habitant on est aujourd'hui
le 25e et on va continuer de dégringoler
les marches on est à peu près sur la
décennie 1% de croissance c'est à dire
le taux que nous avions en 1800 avant
les révolutions qui nous ont apporté les
acquis qui sont les nôtres or quel est
l'impact de cet affaiblissement de la
croissance vous le voyez tous les jours
si vous avez un jour mes jambes et dans
les banlieues le lendemain crise et
gilet jaune le jour d'après une
révolution des fonctionnaires les encore
ensuite une manifestation de ras-le-bol
fiscale c'est parce que moins de
croissance et moins d'emplois c'est
moins de pouvoir d'achat c'est moins de
ressources pour les services publics
c'est plus d'impôts et j'allais dire
aussi c'est plus de difficultés à
intégrer des populations étrangères dont
vous voyez bien que toute une série des
questions qui minent la france sont liés
à ça c'est ça le sujet qui nous occupe
c'est pas tellement de savoir comment on
va consommer est-ce qu'on va trier ses
ordures est ce qu'on va essayer d'éviter
de consommer ça c'est tout à fait
légitime le sujet est globalement quel
est l'impact sur nos sociétés de la fin
de la croissance sans
croissance économique y aura rien à
partager c'est une des phrases que j'ai
lu dans le livre de denis olivennes est
ce que vous êtes d'accord avec cette
idée alors je crois que je suis d'accord
pour qu'on parle de manière globale la
question de la croissance mais il ya
quelque chose que denis olivennes ne dit
pas c'est la question du réchauffement
climatique
et si on veut se placer d'un point de
vue micro ce qu'on voit très bien quand
on regarde les courbes c'est qu'il ya
des des courbes exactement superposables
de la croissance depuis depuis les
années 50 en gros ça devient
exponentielle et des émissions de gaz à
effet de serre donc je dis pas que ça va
être facile je dis que si on est sérieux
on voit bien que la croissance d'une
part elle nous a amené énormément de
bien fait oui elle a amené des normes
bien fait ça je suis ton tout le monde
ne peut qu'être d'accord mais elle a
mené également beaucoup de mots ça veut
dire qu'un 62 personnes maintenant voit
le verso de la médaille par exemple tous
ceux qui écrivent une autre histoire des
trente glorieuses se rendent compte que
finalement on a un peu creuser notre
tombe donc on doit prendre ça en
considération et il faut aussi dire ce
qu'on dit la croissance apparaît c'est
très positif la croissance est très joli
mais qu'est ce que c'est la croissance
c'est le taux de croissance du pib' du
produit intérieur brut c'est quoi le
produit intérieur brut c'est là la
valeur monétaire de ce qu'on produit une
année que ça soit du bon du pas bon
alors on nous dit souvent c'est de la
création de richesse d'accord il ya de
la création de richesses mais ça ne
donne qu'une toute petite image de la
richesse ça nous donne une mauvaise
image complètement inexacte de la
richesse de la de la société on oublie
plein de choses et surtout on oublie ce
que je viens de vous dire c'est à dire
le fait qu'on peut détruire notre
patrimoine naturel et donc on va bien
être obligé d'être face à cette question
et de se demander comment on va faire
avec moins de croissance pour inventer
un nouveau modèle oui mais je crois que
c'est là que sont nés au coeur du débat
parce que on peut c'est vrai que la
croissance jusqu'à une certaine époque
c'est moins vrai d'ailleurs depuis une
vingtaine d'années donc dire qu'on est
en tout cas une dizaine d'années la
croissance jusqu'à une certaine époque
indifférente à la question de
l'environnement on n'était pas conscient
du sujet c'est assez s'est traduite par
les
les émissions de co2 et donc la leaf et
destructive destructeurs sur la planète
mais on peut parfaitement imaginer
de régler cette question ca de découpler
la croissance économique de l'émission
co2 c'est d'ailleurs ce que la france
fait d'ailleurs d'autres pays européens
si vous regardez au cours des 20
dernières années on a réduit nos
émissions co2 donc pro si aujourd'hui le
vrai débat me semble-t-il est celui là c
est ce que pour faire face aux risques
que personne n'a en tous cas ici noni et
dramatique du réchauffement climatique
il faut démolir notre niveau de vie et
notre façon de vivre ensemble ou bien
est ce qu'il faut faire ce que nous
avons fait sur pour relever d'autres
défis dans les 30 dernières années c'est
à dire notamment utiliser l'innovation
qui me permet d'avoir moins d'énergie
pour produire et moins de carbone dans
l'énergie et cette révolution là elle
réelle répond au défi climatique sans
avoir pour ça a changé complètement
notre modèle de société me faire
confiance au génie humain en quelque
sorte et à l'innovation jourdain entendu
thomas passionnant mais aussi wii mais
aussi or la luxure 7 sur cette question
qu'est-ce que vous êtes je pense que
vous faites partie du même si le temps
que que dominique méda pas forcément
d'accord avec denis olivennes si j'ai
bien compris ça fait plus partie les
fondés mais oui j'ai lancé partie avant
non pas tout à fait d'accord et en même
temps ce qu'il apporte dans le débat
extrêmement intéressant alors pas
d'accord pourquoi parce qu'en fait ce
fameux découplage c'est à dire la
capacité de produire toujours plus un
polluant moins
il n'est jamais arrivé hilali et betty
voulu de manière relative c'est à dire
qu'on aimait moins de co2 sur notre sol
sauf qu'on importe énormément énormément
de produits polluants qu'on fait
produire ailleurs souvent d'ailleurs
parce qu'ils sont pour lui un par
ailleurs et donc en fait de découplage
suis femme eu découplage on espère de
nos voeux il n'arrive pas malgré des
innovations technologiques qu'on a
toujours pas de rupture technologique
est d'ailleurs l'agencé européenne de
l'environnement qui est pas spécialement
décroissante east l'a dit récemment elle
a dit le découplage est très peu
probable il n'y a pas de consensus
scientifique donc en fait il faut sortir
du pib ensuite une fois qu'on a posés ça
il faut aussi se rappeler que comme l'a
dit dominique le pib on y attacher d'un
point de vue affectif parce que c'est
une aire d'opulence c'est les trente
glorieuses c'est effectivement le plein
emploi et donner olivennes a
parfaitement dit elle dit la croissance
économique c'est l'emploi c'est la
réduction des inégalités et on a ça
aussi dans notre imaginaire sauf que
maintenant ça n'est plus totalement le
cas c'est à dire que ça fait 40 ans on
se rend compte que le pib décrochent des
cobras de bien-être dans tous les pays
développés c'est à dire qu'au bout d'un
moment le pib ne parvient plus à
améliorer notre bien être tout
simplement parce que quand on a tous on
n'a pas besoin de tout on a besoin de
mieux et notamment de mieux partager les
richesses et en fait c'est ça le débat
aujourd'hui c'est à dire que en abattant
besoin de plus de croissance économique
pour qu'ils aient pas le feu dans les
banlieues pour qu'ils aient pas les
gilet jaune on a besoin de mieux
partager nos richesses et c'est là on se
aussi piégé à la fois par le discours
productiviste mais aussi des néolibéraux
qui nous disent que non non ne partagent
pas les richesses on va on va faire la
croissance économique on augmente la
taille du gâteau plutôt que d'avoir à le
partager et l'allemand fait on est face
à quelque chose qui s'appelle des
limites et nous en tant qu'être humain
on a un petit peu de mal à les lire avec
les limites mais on a les limites de la
biosphère qui s'impose à louer comme
disait certain celui qui pense qu'on
peut croître indéfiniment dans un monde
fini est soit un économiste je me mets
dedans soit un fou donc il faut qu'on
accepte l'idée de limite que la taille
du gâteau et bah oui elle peut pas
grossir indéfiniment même si c'est dur
parce qu'on a été britt prôné à la
consommation de masse et caetera et qu'à
un moment non arena partage
ya des pays qui vont intégrer cette
notion de bien-être j'ai intégré comme
la nouvelle zélande par exemple qui a
voté un budget bien être c'est à dire
que le bien-être des citoyens étaient au
coeur du budget et de la dépense
publique c'est à dire qu'on a mis
davantage d'argent pour par exemple
contre les violences familiales pour le
handicap contre la pauvreté des enfants
et donc on est plus sur une mesure est
un indicateur 1 à 10 pib mais sur du
bien-être donc si ça existe en nouvelle
zélande je parle aussi de peut-être de
finlande en scandinavie ce sont des
modèles qui commence à s'intégrer dans
les sociétés accepter aussi par les
populations parce que ce n'est pas juste
un problème de courage politique ou de
changement de modèle que l'on imposerait
aux populations s'est aussi demandée par
les populations donc c'est vrai que
c'est difficile parce qu'on nous demande
de changer totalement de modèles je
comprends ce que vous dites mais c'est
un peu l'ancien monde versus le nouveau
monde pour lui en vouloir gêner personne
mais c'est vraiment ça c'est à dire que
et c'est une révolution oui c'est à dire
qu'il faut abandonner tout tout ce qu'on
tout ce qu'on nous a effectivement
présenté comme étant des facteurs de
réussite à thomas par outils web
entendait honorer les meilleurs dans les
pays comme ça un peu en pointe ses
boutons qui en 72 a décidé d'avoir des
critères notamment sur le le bonheur
national brut où ils ont intégré sept ou
huit critères notamment l'environnement
est ce que c'est une coïncidence
aujourd'hui le bouton est le seul pays
avec un bilan carbone négatif parce que
dans la constitution il demande à ce que
les 60 % de forêts sur le territoire
voilà donc ça c'est pour continuer sur
les pays vous êtes très pragmatique vous
êtes chef d'entreprise et vous
accompagner des chefs d'entreprise c'est
ce que dit
agnoli veine on peut l'entendre jeudi
suis sensible aussi la capacité du voile
a du génie humain
de l'innovation à faire émerger des
solutions
qu'est ce que vous en pensez mais je
suis assez d'accord avec denis olivennes
dans la mesure où
au moins la croissance moi je suis chef
d'entreprise j'accompagne des grandes
entreprises sur les sujets de transition
est en fait la croissance française je
sais pas trop ce que c'est je suis pas
sûr que emmanuel macron ou bruno le
maire soit six responsables que ça de la
croissance française je pense que c'est
la somme des entreprises françaises
avant tout qu'ils décident d'une
croissance et qui décide de faire
évoluer leur modèle et moi ce que je
constate depuis quelques années c'est
que beaucoup d'entreprises se
développent et réduisent leur bilan
carbone or le carbone est un indicateur
intéressant et on commence à travailler
sur des nouveaux indicateurs il ya
quelque chose qui s'appelle la nec
initiative qui est super intéressante
c'est quoi l'anac initiative c'est cinq
critères évidemment le carbone mais
aussi le respect de la biodiversité
la pollution de l'air la qualité de
l'eau l' inverse et le et un cinquième
critère qui est l'utilisation des
ressources donc on ils sont capables de
noter les entreprises sur d'autres
éléments que juste la croissance et ça
c'est intéressant enfin moi qui suis
communicant c'est que ça participe à la
bonne réputation de l'entreprise donc
parce que de là alors on parlait du
couplage entre croissance économique et
impact carbone
il ya la consommation d'énergie et dans
le monde d'énergie fossile il ya aussi
évidemment l'utilisation des ressources
naturelles la perte de biodiversité
enfin les courbes je suis pas chercheurs
comme vous l'êtes mais je pense qu'elles
sont toutes très très proches les unes
des autres tu as fait tout donc du coup
en fait la question
c'est stop on arrête on fait comment
dernier point c'est que aujourd'hui ce
qu'on sait c'est qu'on a le droit
d'émettre si on veut respecter la courbe
des accords de paille 750 gigatonnes de
co2 jusqu'en 2100 au rythme où on va on
va les faire en sept ans on va exploser
les chiffres donc du coup en fait il
faut tout remettre à plat tout repenser
et je crois que la croissance doit être
complètement repensé et ça doit
évidemment pu être en indicateurs
économiques et que si on veut survivre
jusqu'en 2100 parce que là ce matin par
exemple novethic parler de 2,7 degrés
2,7 degrés ça veut dire des migrations
ça veut dire des maladies partout et
c'est donc il faut tout remettre à plat
tout de suite ce que certaines
entreprises l'ont fait parce qu'elles
ont peut-être un peu de génie français
ou de gène humain denis olivennes je
crois que l'idée qu' il faut substituer
le bien-être à la croissance et que le
bien-être ce serait nouveau monde et la
croissance ancien monde et mais il faut
ce parce que bien sûr il faut qu'on
intègre la dimension moi je suis un
adepte du modèle scandinave donc c'est
pas que je suis un ultralibéral qui veut
que la croissance anarchique le profit
et les inégalités mais on a fait
l'expérience de la non croissance on l'a
fait à l'occasion du coc vide -8% et
s'il n'y avait pas eu d manne d'argent
public qu'on ne peut pas de déverser
advitam eternam
c'était des milliers de gens sans emploi
la fin du pouvoir d'achat leur capacité
de d'acheter et donc on voit bien que
entre ce modèle là on le monde de ce
monde delà de la décroissance on l'a vu
et il est dramatique il est dramatique
pour les pays riches mais imaginez ce
qu'il est pour les pays pauvres qui
n'ont même pas encore aujourd'hui accès
aux hôpitaux aux routes au revenu
minimum donc la vraie question ce n'est
pas de se dire hey décroissance et tour
les pays riches à on ne parle pas de
décroissance pour aller payer
la décroissance dans les pays riches à
de la décroissance dans les pays pauvres
mais je crois que le vrai sujet ce qui
est nouveau monde c'est de faire dans
les années 70 on craignait déjà on
appelait déjà la croissance zéro en
craignant que la clau modèle néo
conduisent à la sous-alimentation
mondiale et à la crise énergétique
il ya eu ni l'un ni l'autre parce que
les innovations permis de faire face je
ne dis pas donc le nez
et se dire mais qu'est ce qu'on peut
faire d'intelligent et d'efficace avec
la ressource infinie que nous avons
c'est à dire le cerveau humain et comme
nous l'avons fait au cours des sk et de
l'accord de niocan changer le modèle je
citais tout alors quid alors de fuir
consommer jeter ça c'est évidemment qu a
nourri la croissance pendant des
décennies il faut évidemment que je suis
d'accord évidemment que je suis d'accord
pour une croissance qui soit orientée en
sorte qu'elles soient respectueuses de
l'environnement évidemment que je suis
pour une croissance qui soit socialement
juste et redistributive
on a beaucoup de progrès à faire et bien
évidemment je ne pense pas que la
croissance soit le seul critère que je
crois que la croissance contribue au
bonheur mais qu'elle ne suffit pas au
bonheur et que le bonheur c'est bien
d'autres choses c'est leur relation
entre nous c'est les niveaux d'éducation
c'est tout un tas de choses je dis
simplement que l'idée que pour réduire
nos émissions de co2 donné notre niveau
de ces au dos et aux deux tendons pour
cela il va falloir détruire notre niveau
de vie ou que pour sauver la planète il
va falloir détruire nos sociétés
montrent non seulement effet une idée
fausse sur le fond mais qui ne
remportera jamais la diffusion de spots
de 10 mai date vous ou presque
koné la parole
je dis simplement qu'on se soutenant
après j'arrête en soutenant cette idée
en soi en étant les avocats d'une
transition brutale énergétique brutale
et sacrificielle où nous saurons mais
une chose me jetteront les peuples
européens alors dans les bras des formes
et donne la parole et se passe par une
citation daniel cohn bendit c'était au
mois d'août 24 août de mémoire dans les
échos la transition écologique en
douceur ça n'existe pas là mais personne
ne veut sa l'année alors d'une part il
ya des grands mots la croissance juste
etc mais la croissance verte tout le
monde commence à se rendre compte que
c'est en effet un mythe et d'autre part
personne ne veut une transition brutale
était au complet ce qu'on peut faire
autrement mais on veut la préparer il
faut la préparer c'est à dire que oui
une décroissance qui nous tomberait
comme ça dessus serait quelque chose
d'absolument catastrophique mais notre
génie humain on doit précisément le
mettre au service de la préparation de
ce nouveau modèle à modèle social
écologique ou ce qu'on cherche ça n'est
pas plus de croissance mais de l'emploi
du plein emploi de la pleine santé la
satisfaction des besoins essentiels de
tout le monde et c est sans doute y aura
un remaniement 1 comment dirais-je un
remodelage au sein de cette croissance
puisque la croissance l'excès aussi bien
la production que les revenus bas au
sein des revenus il y aura certainement
des redistributions mai mais ça se
prépare tous les jours et je voulais
revenir se trouve disait qu'elle était
très très important sur les indicateurs
moi je travaille depuis 20 ans sur la
recherche de nouveaux indicateurs
alternatifs ou complémentaires au pire
il s'agit pas de jeter le produit
intérieur brut mais de lancer et de
l'insérer dans des limites sociales et
environnementales
donc on a créé un espèce de forums
s'appelle le forum pour d'autres
indicateurs de richesse et ce qui est
intéressant c'est qu'on voit que dans le
monde entier plein de personnes
travaille là dessus sur la recherche de
nouveaux indicateurs tant macro que
micro que pour les entreprises parce que
vous voyez que le problème de la delà de
la macro delà de la question de la de la
croissance et de nos indicateurs de
l'indicateur pipe qui n'est pas si
ancien que ça hein ça date de 1945 10
903 45 et 60 notre pipe et il a été
construit au moment où on avait besoin
justement de mesurer des reconstruction
des bâtiments et aujourd'hui on n'est
plus du tout là dedans et aujourd'hui ce
qui nous importe c'est l'empreinte
carbone la cohésion sociale donc moi
avec mes collègues ce que je propose ses
dents serrées le produit intérieur brut
dans l'empreinte carbone d'une part on
dépasse pas certaines limites et dans l'
indice de santé social d'autre part
c'est à dire une juste redistribution de
ça et je pense qu'en tout comme ça en
enfermé en serre et encadrait la
production dans des limites c'est ça
qu'il faut qu'on essaye de faire et ça
ça nous demande un certain génie en
effet ce qui est assez fascinant ce que
quand vous dites mais non on veut à la
fois moins de croissance et plus emploi
il fera que vous nous expliquiez comment
je prends l'exemple je fais une petite
comparaison là on célèbre la fin ou en
tout cas on parle de la fin de 2,2 du
mandat de madame merkel qui a duré 15
ans sur ces 15 dernières années
l'allemagne a vu son produit intérieur
brut rapporté aux habitants a progressé
de 35%
le no 2 n'a progressé que de 10 7%
résultat des courses l'allemagne est
passée d'un taux de chômage de 11 à 4 %
et notre taux de chômage est resté à peu
près stable donc pour qu'ils aient des
emplois après ils peuvent être après une
rixe et engendre des emplois qu'elles
emploient ndt des emplois
mal payés et en général réservées aux
formes mais j'ai bien vu ce que vous ce
que vous ce que vous écrivez mais le
partage du travail allemand c'est le
contraire je sais que vous critiquez les
35 heures mais c'est le contraire d'une
autre qu'est ce qui se passe en
allemagne les femmes travaillent sur des
petits temps partiel mal payés pendant
que les hommes travaillent sur le bon
temps complet bien payés alors que dans
notre pays on a ici et grâce aux 35
heures de rapprocher le temps des hommes
et des femmes sachant que c'est quand
même super important nous les femmes
nous travaillons quatre heures de
travail domestique par jour pendant que
vous travaillez deux heures et demie par
jour c'est le contraire pour le travail
rémunéré dont on doit essayer de faire
converger ces différents temps et moi je
pense pas du tout que le modèle allemand
sentiment du tout et d'ailleurs je n'ai
pas vu un travailleur allemand dépité
par la situation épouvantable qui soit
la sienne franchir la frontière pour
venir travailler chez nous j'ai pas du
tout le sentiment
thibault vous savez bien que c'est ce
sont des injonctions c'est un modèle
dans lequel vous vivez moi je suis
d'accord avec vous madame la situation
de la femme en allemagne elle et elle
est compliqué là ça commence à changer
mais la corse consommait en 2021 oui
commence à pouvoir travailler quand
elles ont des enfants mais une femme qui
a des enfants en allemagne n'y a aucune
n'a aucune aide et céda donc doit rester
à la maison une femme qui est instruite
et qui est diplômé enfin alors que nous
nous sommes là évidemment on ne peut pas
on peut pas comparer donc l'allemagne en
fait là aussi humble hygiène de cette
avenue olivennes modèle voilà jamais ça
c'est la lab le prototype du débat
française alors qu'on fait des choses
que personne ne fait d'autres mondes
face à la question du chômage se
demander comment on augmente l'activité
ans au liban on va le partager résultat
des courses on est le pays du monde qui
travaillent le moins des pays riches
c'est pas vrai pour ceux ci merci faut
ça reste 2018 on travaille ici saison à
venir lorsqu'on travaille 600 heures
pneus ont rapporté au nombre d'habitants
600 heures par an et par habitant
l'allemagne travaillent 700 les
etats-unis travaillent 800 je parle pas
de la quake donc face à la question du
chômage on dit elle était géniale on
partage le travail face à la question de
la difficulté scolaire qui et quelle
idée géniale on massifie et aux moyennes
l'éducation nationale se couper des
élèves les plus en difficulté résultat
des courses d'après les enquêtes de l'
ocde on l système scolaire à la fois le
plus efficace et le plus injuste du
monde est maintenant face à la question
du réchauffement climatique
au lieu de se poser la question de
savoir comment on va pouvoir soutenir
une activité qui créent des emplois et
du pouvoir d'achat tout en faisant en
sorte qu'elle soit compatible à la croix
avec la croissance on va rentrer dans le
cycle de l'emploi on veut de l'emploi et
enfin à voir et ces pressions à vous
m'expliquer on crée de l'emploi sans
croissance est recommandé aux autres
mois que l'activité on crée de l'emploi
s'est pressé m alain ce qu'on a vu
récemment encore comment dans les
situations cordelle on le voit est la
france on voit avec la france que
l'affaiblissement par étape de sa
croissance puisqu'on est maintenant 1% a
eu un impact très négatif on autres
enfants a précisément si on s'engage
dans la reconversion écologique et donc
on utilise moins d'adjuvants chimiques
et mécaniques c'est à dire qu'on
consomme moins d'énergie qu'on va avoir
besoin de plus de travail et maintenant
celle que l'on voulait faire un cas
d'école autour de la 5g histoire assez
incroyable dans l'actualité aujourd'hui
c'est ces moines qui se sont attaqués à
des antennes relais 5 g ça s'est passé
c'est à saint fort journée au nord ouest
de de lyon ils ont été mis en examen
pour destruction et tentative de
destruction par moyen incendiaires et
association de malfaiteurs pour des
moines c'est quand même étonnant des
moines anti 5 gr évidemment moi j'ai
pensé tout de suite à une déclaration du
président de la république qui défend
des vous en souvenez le déploiement de
la 5g et qui critiquait la décroissance
et le fameux je ne crois pas au modèle
hammiche en écoute le prêt dans la
république
la france va prendre le tournant de la
5g parce que c'est le tournant de
l'innovation et j'entends beaucoup de
voix qui s'élèvent pour nous expliquer
qu'il faudrait relever la complexité des
problèmes contemporains en revenant à la
lampe à huile je ne crois pas au modèle
amish et je ne crois pas que le modèle
amish permettent de régler les défis de
l'écologie contemporaine je me tourne
vers or la lutte qui nous écoute depuis
tout à l'heure mais qui est plus d'un
qui n'intervenait plus dans le débat et
c'est de ma faute donc je vous rends là
la parole sur l'a5 j'y jouais vraiment
qu'on fasse un focus là dessus et puis
plus généralement sur ce qu'on appelle à
la sobriété où la pollution numérique la
5g est-ce qu'on peut s'en passer or là
luc
non en fait on peut pas s'en passer dans
le modèle dans lequel on est aujourd'hui
c'est ça la difficulté si vous voulez on
est dans un modèle qui forcément créer
en permanence des innovations
technologiques dont on n'a pas forcément
besoin on a peut-être besoin mais
peut-être qu'on n'a pas moi même je ne
sais pas vous voyez parce que on a pas
de débat on n'a pas la possibilité
d'avoir du recul d'avoir une réflexion
vis-à-vis de notre progrès
technologiques est ce qu'on a besoin
d'un 5 g ou est-ce qu'il faut mettre nos
forces ailleurs aujourd'hui tout ça on
n'a pas le temps d'en parler on est pris
dans un espèce de cycle comme ça que
nous qui nous dépasse totalement donc
moi même vous voyez en tant que
consommatrice je suis surprise un mec
contradictions il faut se le dire
clairement est ce que si elle à 5 g je
vais la prendre ou pas peut-être que je
vais la prendre voilà typiquement en
fait il ya un moment on a besoin d'avoir
une vraie réflexion sur le progrès
technologique on a besoin de savoir où
est ce qu'on met les moyens on a besoin
aussi de ralentir tout simplement d'un
système et je reviens sur ce qui a été
dit auparavant sur la création notamment
de de l'emploi les énergies fossiles
j'aimerais pas bon avoir la lutte mais
je vais vous interromps parce qu'on va
pas avoir le temps de revenir sur le
débat précédent
ça crée des emplois dans l'agriculture
biologique la rénovation thermique des
bâtiments les renouvelables etc alors
merci beaucoup thomas parouty est ce que
les entreprises évidemment ma question
est très général ça dépend des secteurs
mais ce qu'elles peuvent se passer de la
salle g je pense que c'est avant tout
enfin évidemment que les entreprises
vont en profiter mais c'est avant tout
pour les consommateurs est ce qu'on
constate dans ce type d'innovation c'est
l'effet rebond c'est à dire que j'ai un
outil qui est beaucoup plus puissant
donc du coup je vais beaucoup plus
utilisés oui voilà si on utilisait
autant que avec la 4g globalement nos
points de vue environnemental je crois
que c'est assez proche mais du coup on
va plus on va regarder des films sur nos
téléphones et on sait tous qu'un film
sur netflix c'est à peu près la
consommation d'un frigo pendant deux ans
voilà un film c'est deux ans donc et on
sait à peu près et jeune denis qui
travaillent et qui s'occupait de la fnac
à une époque un dvd c'est à peu près le
même bilan carbone voilà donc je pense
que la 5g était pas forcément une
priorité
oui mais si on la déploie pas là la
france est en retard c'est un vrai
argument certainement et donc il faut
certainement prendre le train de
l'innovation mais
certainement enfin moi je pense qu'il ya
un sujet d'éducation quand même là
dessus et on voit bien aujourd'hui que
les différentes crises dont on parle et
vert en fait sont des révélateurs de
deux classes qui populaires qui n'ont
pas forcément conscience des enjeux et
donc on augmente en baisse la vitesse de
10 km heure on augmente la taxe carbone
ce qui est quand même pilote dans notre
bilan carbone et on voit la réaction
très violente qu'on a eues avec les
gilets jaunes je pense que le politique
un problème monstrueux c'est
qu'aujourd'hui on a un bilan carbone par
tête d'habitant en france qui est à peu
près de 11,6 à vous savez aujourd'hui
déplacement on dit souvent qu'il autour
du 1er août mais en france il est plutôt
autour du 1er mai est en fait l'homme
politique un peu père de famille devrait
dire pour l'apprendre prochaine campagne
2022 je sais pas si je vais pas proposer
ça d'ailleurs on passe de 1,6 à 2 tonnes
sauf que il est doucement
ou dix ans sauf que ouais mais sauf que
comme on n'a que s'étant enfin il ya une
véritable urgence donc il ya un gros
sujet quand même sur l'éducation sur
excuses et moins chers amis mais sur le
rôle des médias aussi dans cette
éducation de tous les médias pour faire
comprendre les échelles les ont et
bastien gestion on va faire un peu de
pédagogie avec samia déchire qui va nous
nous rejoindre pour une chronique sur
alors on pourrait parler
venez ça mais on pourrait parler de
frugalité de sobriété numérique ou de de
pollution numérique ou est ce que vous
direz qu'on est en retard dans ce
domaine oui on est en retard rien n'a
pas toujours conscience mais on pollue
parfois plus avec son téléphone qu'en
prenant l'avion une question pour vous
thomas par exemple est-ce que vous triez
votre boîte mail oui on va vous êtes sur
la voie de la décroissance c'est bien
parce qu'il faut savoir que 10000 mais
stocké pendant un an sur votre boite
mail bien c'est l'équivalent d'un trajet
en voiture entre paris et marseille donc
c'est pas rien parce que toutes les
données qui est dans nos mains il est
bien évidemment elles sont stockées sont
ok physiquement dans des serveurs qui
polluent qui consomment beaucoup
d'énergie au sénat il ya une mission
d'information qui s'est penché sur le
sujet l'an dernier et dans son rapport
et bien on apprend que si rien n'est
fait en 2040 le numérique va représenter
presque 7 % des gaz à effet de serre qui
sont produits par la france 7 % c'est
bien plus que ce que produit aujourd'hui
le secteur aérien c'est à dire 4,7 pour
cent de nos émissions de gaz à effet
alors justement à la suite de ce rapport
est une proposition de loi pour lutter
contre la pollution numérique ch oui
c'était un texte qui s est l'argent on y
trouve beaucoup de propositions entre
autres une éducation dès le plus jeune
âge à la sobriété numérique dans le tri
et ses mails regarder - de vidéo en
streaming sur son téléphone cette
proposition de loi elle prévoit aussi de
lutter contre l'obsolescence des
logiciels avec des sanctions à la clé
pour les fabricants faut savoir par
exemple qu'un smartphone en france il a
une durée de vie de moins de 2 ans et 23
mois alors qu'il faut 200 kg de matière
pour en produire un seul et puis cette
proposition de loi elle prévoit aussi
d'interdire les forfaits téléphoniques
qui donne un accès illimité aux données
on va comprendre pourquoi avec patrick
chaize qui est un sénateur l'un des
auteurs de cette proposition de loi on
n'imagine pas sur d'autres services tels
que l'eau et l'électricité que et bien
ça soit open bar c'est à dire que six
jeunes chauffés à 25 est ce qu'il est
normal que ça soit la collectivité dans
son ensemble qui financent bon ma
demande l'exigence et c'est pareil pour
l'aspect numérique alors cette
proposition précise d'interdire les
forfaits avec des données illimitées en
fait elle a vraiment peu de chances
d'être adoptée puisque elle a été
rejetée en première lecture à
l'assemblée nationale mais il ya plein
d'autres propositions dans ce texte qui
devrait revenir en novembre au sénat
merci ça bien pour cet éclairage denis
olivennes on est au coeur de du débat
parce que le l'outil numérique la
digitalisation dans une société c'est
aussi un levier de transformation
écologique donc c'est le paradoxe de de
cet outil il faut qu'on apprenne à
l'utiliser à le consommer d'une façon
plus sobre plus frugale vous diriez ça
très simplement je je suis un chaud
partisan des normes c'est l'un des
outils de la transition écologique c'est
la norme donc si il faut
générer d'énormes pour éviter les
dommages collatéraux écologique de telle
ou telle innovation j'y suis falloir
mais en revanche je suis absolument
défavorable à l'idée qu' il faudrait
ralentir pour utiliser une expression
que j'ai entendu la france est déjà
extrêmement en retard on investit moins
dans la recherche et le développement
d'autres on aux universités sont moins
bien financé on est le 12ème pays
européen pour l'innovation on a tout un
tas de petits pays dont nous la suisse
la suède le danemark 16 donc on est en
retard sur l'innovation et donc là
encore le nouveau monde me semble-t-il
c'est plutôt de se demander comment on
va accélérer sur le chemin de
l'innovation non pas pour avoir des
innovations qui détruisent
l'environnement mais pour utiliser les
innovations au service environnement et
si vous permettez d'élargir un peu figé
je pense qu'on fait
trois erreurs
dans la façon dont on pense le débat si
on pense le débat que moi en se disant
il faut qu'on ait une croissance
compatible avec l'environnement de la
première heure qu'on fait c'est que
aujourd'hui on sait que
l'argent investi dans la transition
écologique des pays en développement est
infiniment plus rentable pour ralentir
les émissions de co2 que chez nous
aujourd'hui si vous transformez dans
tous les pays du monde en dehors des
pays développés descente et vieilles
centrales thermiques au charbon qui
émettent épouvantablement du co2 si nous
les pays riches on investissait dans ces
pays en voie de développement pour
permettre de d'avoir des centrales de
nouvelle génération voire des centrales
nucléaires
décarbonés on ferait un gain d'amélie
d'un une amélioration des émissions
mondiales bon état la deuxième chose la
deuxième erreur qu'on commet c'est qu'il
ya des choses qu'on pourrait faire à
l'échelle du monde et qu'on ne fait pas
parce que le co2 c'est les émissions
mais c'est aussi le fait qu'on le stock
la forêt la mère et le sol stockent du
co2 sont des puits de carbone il ya des
programmes pourraient investir
mondialement massivement pour augmenter
les pauvres forrest et pour augmenter la
capote et de la capacité stockage delà
des océans et la capacité se cachent des
sols et on ne fait pas donc voilà deux
est par ailleurs dans nos pays à nous il
faut qu'on mette en place des normes des
taxes carbone qui permet d'orienter la
consommation et l'investissement vers le
rpg au bouchon jeudi d' avance que si
cette transition est trop brutal on va
le voir là on va aujourd'hui
l'électricité en europe c'est à peu près
100 dollars le 100 euros le kilowatt
heure elle va encore augmenter sous
l'effet des taxes et vous allez voir la
réaction de dépopulation parlé ici-même
allait il nous reste moins de trois
minutes je vais faire un dernier tour de
table avec des réponses courtes les les
unes et les autres or la lui que je
vouvoyais mois dans l'écran de contrôle
réagir aux propos de denis olivennes
qu'est ce que ça vous inspire sam aspire
que penser que la forêt ça peut être un
puits de carbone penser que l'océan ça
peut être des puits de carbone basse est
en train de quoi l'acidification des
océans ça fait que la forêt dans un a
pas besoin que pour être un puits de
carbone on en a besoin aussi pour faire
de la biodiversité en fait va falloir
arrêter de réduire la nature à des
fonctions qui nous arrange il va falloir
accepter qu'on doit accepter justement
ses limites et cesser de penser qu'à un
moment on va avoir une révolution
technologique va nous permettre de
continuer comme avant
ce n'est pas possible et on peut pas
faire ce pari c'est trop risqué donc
maintenant il faut changer le
métabolisme sociale de notre société
nous réorganiser et mettre notre génie
là dedans parce que on est plusieurs à
sonner l'alarmé depuis 20 ans est à dire
qu il faut qu on se réorganise et qu'on
mette de nouvelles politiques
macroéconomiques en place et en fait on
est bloqué à chaque fois par ce type de
discours qui fait que oui au bout d'un
moment la transition malheureusement
sera brutal nous ont pas ce que j'ai dit
olli rehn a parlé trop longtemps non
contre
moi je pense qu'il faut redire pour
répondre à denis olivennes qui a mis de
la croissance verte c'est à dire ça je
crois que maintenant on est à peu près
convaincu que ça ne marche pas et je
pense qu'il faut s'entendre sur le terme
d'innovation denis olivennes dit il faut
plus d'innovation oui il faut plus
d'innovations mais laquelle pas
nécessairement plus numérique plus de
nom il faut plus d'innovation sociale
plus de gène humain pour voir justement
comment va anticiper les nouveaux
emplois comment on va faire les
reconversions comment on va faire
comment admettre beaucoup plus de gens
dans l'agriculture comment va avoir une
forme d'anti déversement assauts vie
disait les ont réduit les effectifs dans
l'agriculture puis dans le secondaire
plus de l'intérieur moi je pense au
contraire qu'on va avoir énormément de
créations d'emplois dans le secteur
primaire et secondaire et c'est là qu'on
doit mettre toute notre intelligence
merci beaucoup à tous et pardon de ne
pas avoir pu donner la parole une
dernière fois de ma part outils et
lætitia un cru pas merci à tous les cinq
d'avoir participé à ce débat denis
olivennes un étrange renoncement publiés
chez albin-michel dominique méda je vais
citer la mystique de la croissance
commence en libérer c'est chez
flammarion aurore laluque pour
reconquête au nom de l'intérêt général
on est auto éditions les petits matins
demain matin 8 heures vous avez rendez
vous dans la matinale dorian mansigné
avec damien abad ce sera l'interview
politique le président a l'air du groupe
a l'air à l'assemblée nationale je vous
dis à demain pour aller au numéro deux
sens public salue